How should the US government and the rest of us respond to the Coronavirus,
which has just been declared a global pandemic by the World Health Organization.
Balaji Srinivasan, who was on the short list to head up Donald Trump's Food and Drug Administration,
has some strong opinions.
He's a former venture capitalist at Andreessen Horowitz, and he's a serial entrepreneur
with a Phd in electrical engineering. The genetic testing company he cofounded, Counsyl,
helped change the way millions of people prepare for parenthood, and his cryptocurrency startup, Earn.com,
was acquired by Coinbase, where he served as chief technology officer.
In a prescient, lively, and constantly updated Twitter feed, Srinivasan has been way ahead of the curve
in noting the Coronavirus's spread, and potential to cause a global public health crisis,
and a massive economic and social disruption to life as we know it.
Balaji, thanks for talking. Hello.
Let's get right to it, you were really early
in sounding the alarm about Coronavirus,
how did you hear about it and why were you on top of it,
and what does that say about Silicon Valley versus journalists on the east coast?